DC fans have been eagerly awaiting a
sequel to injustice gods among us but
the mobile version of the game has
received a steady stream of updates the
latest is the biggest one in over a year
and it rolls in content from the newest
DC Universe film Suicide Squad fans of
Harley Quinn and the Joker should be
pleased first off Will Smith Deadshot is
joining the game as a new character the
Joker and Harley Quinn are already
present but they're getting new skins to
match their movie costumes on top of
that challenge multiplayer and survival
modes are getting suicide squad theme
rewards and companion cards and did I
mention this is all free this isn't the
first movie tie-in the game is received
Batman V Superman content was available
for a limited time this spring so you
better grab the Suicide Squad stuff
while it's hot injustice gods among us
is available on iOS and Android and if
you're waiting for news on the console
sequel coming next year you're already
in the right place